[Music]
hi everybody i'm lauren zima
i'm denny direct oh thank you so much
for joining us here on ET live for the
official recap of the 69th Annual
Primetime Emmy Awards yes the show just
ended so we're going to be going over
the biggest moments the snub is the
surprises the people we thought would
and the people who did win so we want to
know what you guys thought of the show
leave your comments and questions on ET
Facebook page right now and we will get
them here on our iPad and duggie knife
we're a little tired cuz we were
actually at the show we don't just like
this just for fun it was such a good
night we can give you guys some insight
and of course head to ET online calm for
all of the big red carpet moments let's
dive in I mean there's so many talking
about big moments of the show but I want
to kick things off with the big little
sweep my big little lives we were fans
of this limited series from the
beginning and we've been a fan boy and
fangirling out like for everybody on
this show and boy did they sweep it not
only do they take outstanding limited
series laura dern won four outs for
supporting actress alexander skarsgård
one for supporting actor and queen
nicole kidman took it for lead actress
in the limited series or movie which was
such a competitive race this season yes
that was what everybody was saying was
maybe the tightest race of the whole
night it was so awesome that alexander
skarsgård won cuz he told he - he really
wanted to win so he's her TV husband and
she was the TV wife and Nicole Kidman
gave the sweetest acceptance speech you
guys we're gonna play a little bit of it
for you
are you also my mother I have two little
girls sunny and faith and my darling
Keith who I asked to help me pursue this
artistic path and they have to sacrifice
so much for it so this is yours I want
my little girls to have this on their
shelf and to look at it and go every
time my mama didn't put me to bed it's
because of this so sweet oh my god she
is a woman who can do it all and then
you see Keith Urban and Reese
Witherspoon in the audience both tearing
up with joy for her and when she first
came on stage she said Reese this is for
you and me it's both it was a perfect
speech I have to say no that is how it's
done folks that is a pro that
you know you get a lot of accolades and
you're an acclaimed actress when you get
up there and say a speech like that
thought she absolutely nailed it moved
us to tears and Keith Urban what a
problem huh be oh my god you guys we
have to tell you so on the red carpet
let me paint this picture when the
actors and actresses get to the red
carpet et were the first ones there we
have this big platform they come and
talk to us Nicole Kidman is being
interviewed and Keith Urban is just
standing there staring at her in awe of
this woman and then as they're walking
by just gonna grab Keith for a little
moment you know he didn't do interviews
but he's like she's looking extremely
beautiful tonight I couldn't be more
proud of her I'm always this proud of
her I love them know their couple goals
relationship goals but moving on to
another big moment of the show of course
Stephen Colbert was the night's host I
thought he killed it I thought it was so
so funny it was a politically charged
monologue and then I don't think anyone
saw this coming it was a surprise
appearance by none other than Sean
Spicer not Melissa McCarthy Sean actual
Spicer I think we have a little clip for
you guys in case you missed it is there
anyone who could say how big the
audience is Sean do you know
this will be the largest audience to
witness and Emmys period both in person
and around the world wow that really
soothes my fragile ego I can understand
why you'd want one of these guys around
Melissa McCarthy everybody give it up I
think it quickly became such a viral
moment people are still talking about it
but two notable reactions one Melissa
McCarthy who played Sean Spicer on SNL
was kind of like oh no they didn't like
they did they really get Sean Spicer
here at the beef of course a politically
charged shown itself her jaw dropped
she's like I mean people are getting
those reactions it truly was a moment of
witnessing hollywood being surprised
they were reacting along with the rest
of us
and by the way Anna Chlumsky reactions
have been like that throughout the whole
show I mean I think anyone is more
stoked to be at the Emmys then that veep
star I know it was amazing and of course
we want to know what you guys thought of
it were you surprised were you not the
thing is people knew that this show it
kind of had to make yeah I mean how
could you not make those political jokes
and it was it was awesome to have him
out there so that was three big
reactions and you know speaking of a
show that's political SNL I know right
it kind of swept to the night you know
they mentioned to us on the carpet Colin
Jost talked to Lauren and he told us
he's like you know what if it wasn't for
the current administration and the
current political climate they're not
sure sure SNL would be what it is today
and clearly it paid off because not only
did they win
outstanding variety sketch series Alec
Baldwin one Supporting Actor in a Comedy
Series for his portrayal of President
Donald Trump I mean I kind of called
that I think we all did that was Emmy
worthy I think and also came a Kenyan
who was up against two of our cast
members won Outstanding Supporting
Actress in a comedy series for second
time in a row so a lot of love for SNL
yeah and you know what kate mckinnon
winning kind of shows how much people
love her too because you would think
with those multiple SNL noms that like
SNL fans might split the votes but
people just really love Kate I'm an et
talk to her backstage she was hilarious
telling us which after-party she's going
to be going to so that'll be up soon
Aditi online.com and yeah it's just
really impressive that SNL how many
years and decades into being a show
so many years so many seconds and still
on the forefront of that commentary you
know despite the rise of the internet
despite things that go viral so quickly
days later they still have a lot to say
about what's going on in our world over
four decades I think they've been around
and they're still collecting these
trophies yes
forty two seasons guys forty two seasons
of SNL it's kind of insane and you guys
your comments are coming in sandy says
so happy for Nicole was a beautiful
speech agreed and Paula says love that
sterling Kate brown when well-deserved
we're gonna get to that poem we are
great
so SNL just sweeping the night in many
ways and then we also had a lot of
history making record-breaking
absolutely including Donald Glover he
was nominated multiple nominations for a
freshman series Atlanta it was a very
buzz worthy show coming into the awards
and I think Donald was a clear
front-runner but not only did he take
outstanding actor in a comedy series for
which she was so excited about he also
became the very first he's first ever
black best director in a comedy winner
miss we dedicated that to his family his
fans he said he's a fan like everybody
else and I think it was a really special
moment so another record breaker right
there yes and he revealed that he is
expecting baby number two during his
speech and we asked him about that
backstage so again you can head over to
ICI online.com so a really big night for
him and then also on Hulu making waves
with The Handmaid's Tale winning another
sweeper just get in there and swiffering
Handmaid's Tale won so many awards
tonight and out was a surprise win we'll
get to that and then Hulu became the
first streaming service to win
outstanding series for The Handmaid's
Tale it's like their game of Thrones
it's kind of speaking of it's so funny
that you mentioned that because I have
to say Game of Thrones was ineligible
this year for the Emmys so it opened up
the race for Larry anybody to take it
and I love that so many new freshmen TV
series we recognize Atlanta among them
Handmaid's Tale so I was really excited
to see someone new become a possible
Emmy darling right yeah and now Amazon's
just gonna kind of pop it in there I
gotta give a shout out to Netflix I feel
like they set the stage for that you
know yeah I took it but I mean it
wouldn't be what it is it without
Netflix and [ __ ] services like that
it's awesome I think there was something
that everybody agreed about on the red
carpet tonight is just that this time
for
television is unbelievable in terms of
the quality of shows that we're getting
more comments coming in from you guys
Robin says that glad big a little lies
one along with SNL Ashley says Star Wars
taking the Emmys Laura Dern Donald
Glover is I'm mad yes yes yes so true
but that Star Wars cast members are just
taking any tonight yeah I love that big
- and Bonnie loved this year's Emmy
Stephen did a great job he really did
another history-maker tonight was master
of none Lina Waits
she became the first african-american
woman to win an Emmy for comedy writing
it was such a touching speech we want to
play a little bit of that for you guys
now standing here I want to thank my
mother for inspiring the story and allow
me to share it with the world I love you
mom Thank You Aziz for pushing me to
co-write this bro now we're standing
here I love you forever thank you and
Alan for creating a show like master of
none we could tell stories like this
Thank You Netflix and Universal for
creating a beautiful playground for us
to play on and shine tents nd we love
you
Molina you are magic Angela you're a
legend Kim you are force thank you for
so so special so our girlfriend I love
you more than life itself
Ilana my team my chosen family I love
y'all and last we're starting not least
my LGB cutie I a family her speech was
so inclusive and it was just such a raw
emotional moment because you know she's
not a name that is a household name so
it was just somebody who's worked really
hard in this industry winning I talked
her on the red carpet before the show
and she was just as genuine and
wonderful then we're in a very cool
jacket by the way we also ask everybody
about the amazing fashion tonight so
we'll talk you guys can head over to our
website for more coverage on that but
she just talked about you know the
support of her girlfriend she talked
about the support of Aziz Ansari and how
they've just trail blazed with this show
and how grateful she is for all of it
and she told us that she's also sure he
felt like a winner she was just excited
to be a part of the show so I feel like
she maybe had a speech prepared but no
matter what she was there to have a good
time like she was just so genuinely
happy to be
and just included can I say I will never
forget this quote and I asked her to
write it into masterhood she said about
her girlfriend she's not a trophy
girlfriend but she is a prize write that
into your show guys moving on to a huge
record breaker no surprise here but
Julia Louie Dreyfus earned her sixth
consecutive Emmy for veep yes for
playing president Selina Meyer I mean
her six the only actress to do so for
the same role she just always kills it
at awards shows and I continue to
petition will she please host an awards
show because that woman is so talented
and amazing and every speech she gives
she cracks us up though she touches our
hearts and again another kind of genuine
overall agreement on the red carpet from
so many people was that Julia Louie
Dreyfus is like the queen of her game
she is one of the most talented comedic
actresses of all time so deserving of
these wins and veep won in several
categories tonight's so good for veep
because they just announced that's gonna
be the last season the show seems so
bummed about that but you know what I
have to say I'm excited for the nominees
after the beep is gone cuz I for the
past six years I feel like have you been
nominated with Julia Louie Dreyfus
you're probably many of you guys are
saying what many of us were wondering if
a lot of people would be saying across
the country Jamie I was happy for
Handmaid's Tale Lisa need to start
watching handmade tale
I feel like that's the thing a lot of
people are have recognized and becomes
obsessed and been drop binge watch this
show but for those who haven't after
tonight they're like I got it watch hand
me stay what am I missing out on here I
got the ketchup right Adrienne says
Nicole Kidman looked amazing she did
that red gown was unbelievable up close
it was insane - so let's move into hand
mate still with some of the snaps and
surprises of the night a big surprise
here I think yes another a woman who's
not a household name but has been
working in the industry a long time and
Dowd won Best Supporting Actress for her
role in Handmaid's Tale her speech was
also just super sweet and this was her
the first time this year she's ever been
nominated for an Emmy she got nominated
for this and for the leftovers I'm I
interviewed her a couple times this
weekend and those interviews are up I
just couldn't stop listening to the
woman speak she's like this angelic
presence I'd love her can I say I think
your peoples good luck charm tonight
like you talk to so many
in any oh my god get over here just say
a word who are you wearing
[Laughter]
another amazing surprise actually is
Elisabeth Moss who won for Lead Actress
in a Drama Series for The Handmaid's
Tale guys get this she has been
nominated nine previous times most of
them from Mad Men of course and this was
her first win I thought she was so
desert of this another role that was so
impactful and not only is she like
burned a hole through the screen she was
so good in there yeah I kind of love
that you know she was snubbed year after
year for Mad Men and now she wins for a
pretty amazing show with a lot of women
in the cast and loved that in the
leading role because she's supported in
that men you know culture trophy girl
congratulations yes she just worked her
way up and you know how do people are
like did she see the brilliance of TV
because she hasn't done many movie roles
but she just killed it on TV series
after series now a possible bit of a
snub here this is us you guys now
somebody commented earlier that they
loved that sterling one and we did too
because sterling can't Browns speech
just now is amazing and actually he told
me on Friday at a carpet that he didn't
even have a speech prepared he didn't
have anything written that suspect do
you not believe him because I'm so good
so good I mean I believe him to be
genuine yeah it speak from the heart but
you kind of have to prepare something
maybe had bullet points and he's so
charismatic and he just lights up any
stage he's on but he won but this is us
overall you know everybody was wondering
is this gonna be the year the network
drama comes back because a network drama
has not won since 2006 mm yeah exactly
so it's been over there right 2006 yeah
24 it was in 2006 yeah yeah so it's been
a while and this is us did not manage to
break that curse but you know it's only
been one season so we've got many
seasons to come
I was gonna say we're gonna get a lot
more love from this is us across the
boards this upcoming TV season with
season 2 drops I'm just calling that
right now I know it's kind of crazy that
it we're only up to season 2 because the
love for this show has been so strong
people can't stop talking 11 total Emmy
nominations this year so I think that's
why I was kind of like a front-runner in
a lot of races because it just earned so
many accolades but happy sterling won I
hit so desert made and you know what
this is us isn't going anywhere so no
and how funny and like small world is
Hollywood sometimes milo ventimiglia
from this is us and Alexis Bledel from
handmade sail both at the Emmys tonight
formerly on Gilmore Girls
in the revival dated at one point it's
just I love Hollywood Star Wars
characters apparently we collected some
Emmys tonight also tonight there was the
9 to 5 reunion with Dolly Parton and
Lily Tomlin and Jane Fonda who each
earned an Emmy nomination this year -
yeah I do love Hollywood I love
Hollywood Lisa says and out is why I
love awards shows a little-known actor
winning and appreciating it so much she
was so overcome it was amazing
so let's talk you know kind of our
favorite moments what was yours I didn't
love that 95 reunion I had to give a
shout-out to Oprah at the end there
because she was Oprah being Oprah and
even in the voice-over and being the
nominees for Outstanding Drama you hear
better call Saul Yeah right this is us
like it was so classic Oprah I love that
I love that she came out she said this
is the final award it's like I am Oprah
obviously here I am so with you on that
Judy look amazing Christa's Jane Fonda
was slaying with that ponytail Chris you
see it I talked to her and guess who she
told us she's inspired by Gwen Stefani
Jane Fonda wanted a Gwen Stefani look
god I love her but she ain't no
hollaback girl I love this trend of
women we're talking Oprah we're talking
Jane Fonda one of my favorite moments of
the night we talked about when Nicole
won on her own but one of my favorite
moments was when big little lies won and
Reese Witherspoon and a quote Kinmen get
up there and you can tell that it's just
the realization of a lot of hard work
for them is waiting for this show and
they just talked about you know getting
women on TV and getting them in these
great parts and Reese has been very
active in saying like look she wasn't
happy with the parts that were being
presented to her as an actor so she went
out and she made something on her own
that she could be proud of it isn't it
amazing to see those two women stand up
there collecting that trophy as
producers of the show and creating this
work for other women I mean Nicole
Kidman even said that this started at a
out of a friendship and became an
opportunity so congrats on that that was
a that was a highlight speech good good
so guys of course like I said et is all
over the Emmys this year we were on the
red carpet we are backstage right now
we're gonna be the after parties so
definitely head to et online calm for
all the latest and you of course watch
ET tomorrow night to see the best
fashion moments and everything you
didn't see you know don't forget to join
us back here at ET spaces page tomorrow
morning at 10:00 a.m. we are breaking
down all the fashion on the red carpet
tonight so and we'll probably sprinkle
in some backstage moments from you guys
from our interviews with et we always
want to know your thoughts we want to
say thank you to our friends at Fiji
water for helping us get this off the
ground and talking Emmys and letting us
do what we love so thanks to Fiji water
keeping us hydrated on the red carpet
and thank you guys for watching we'll
see ya bye guys
[Music]